hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing SG 17 here and it's a little bit
of a morning session I've got my coffee
here yeah that move water is not very
common
okay you can go 96 of course and this
fine line but is there anything better
here really ma'am I mean I can try to be
a bit more cunning here yeah maybe this
this is generally okay I got quite early
pressure on your horn here with this
quick rookie aid okay
one one one interesting question is if
Bishop g5 is something that now it's
probably not very problematic whenever
the bishop is outside of this chain you
have to worry a little bit more about
the pin yeah but I think it's not a big
problem
I got this temple I'm not sure where
he's going probably be three looks like
the most active square but you can argue
that sorry that maybe I'm um
f1 is also a good one it's taking a long
time is that such a big decision I just
saw an interesting little idea if I go
Bishop f3 then f3 I can take but okay
Bishop g4 is kind of a it doesn't make
any sense the air Queen d2 is a good
reply anyway I'm going age six that was
my idea
and now after Bishop h4 I have no g6 and
can ultimately break that pin
all right so is it now no it's no
particular idea I just wonder if I have
something better but this is not I can't
play Bishop g4 Queen d2 yeah I like that
actually let's do that he cannot go
everyw yeah because I simply take it
bishop f3 gfp should be 4 wins for black
so he will he has to play Queen d2 yeah
there's just no other move now knight c6
and he probably will drop back to g3 and
then Knight h5 Nets me the bishop Pam
you know that's good and it's not just
like I get the bishop in which is nice I
mean you probably know that I'm a bishop
pam phonetic in some way but it's also
quite good to have some traits going on
I've got a little bit of a space
disadvantage and some trading this is
good what is he thinking about it is
that such a big decision I mean really
kind of surprised Bishop d3 is kind of
mandatory okay
I mean mandatory was a bit strong but I
wonder yeah is it really such a big
thing okay um probably I'm just going
back and kick it out with a6 next I only
have to check a bit a map map it's a
little bit loose at the moment like g6
is unprotected due to the pin g4 is
unprotected this is always something to
watch out for if you have a little bit
of a if something is not quite
harmonious in your position it's
something that points to being a little
bit more observant him what
okay f7 it's a double attack
not a move ahead on the radar and I have
some doubts about it this is really good
okay if I call 95 yeah I can't go here
just 95 I mean if it takes be seven I'm
going to play Knight f3 and kill him Mia
that is just going to be killing 93 I
mean I'm attacking with everything even
an even Queen f6 should win well let's
go 93m it's it's just a killer at
threaten Queen g5 and is there's simply
no way to stop that I also have c5 on
this I mean he has got two knights and
the bishop that is that does not defend
yeah absolutely not let move I did not
see before hand but it still won't work
I don't believe it
Queen h4 Queen h4 9 Queen h3 and I mean
I did a sloppy calculation job but I
don't believe that you can that cannot
work with all the pieces here
okay this here that's just okay it's
made but it was it was just not going to
be defensible it was a bit odd 25 so um
let's have a look at this um we had this
opening this is interesting by the way
white tries to avoid for example the
petrov and tries to get into a scotch
game the drawback of this move order is
that
and besides 96 which would transpose
there is Bishop c5 or Bishop b4
check but should be for check it's also
a good line um where white is basically
forced to give up another pawn something
like that is going to happen and I'm not
really convinced that white has enough
for the pawn I actually doubt it
this is also a good line however my
recommendation is to play this move
which is also quite good the idea is
that after Knight takes black is not
going knight c6 but plays Knight f6 and
goes for a quick King side development
this quick rook e8 that we saw in the
game I think black has a very
comfortable position here it is just
that White's central position is
slightly shaky and I see no problems at
all you can debate here I mean grabbing
this pawn is also quite tempting yeah
because me it's a bit Department but
this is a good line okay here ah sorry
Bishop c4 I wasn't quite sure if I
should go Knight f6 first on d6 Knight
f6 there might be e5 and this is usually
usually not that great form white but I
wasn't totally certain like because it's
it's going to be very messy this is very
similar to the max Langer attack it's
just there are some twists of course
it's tough to say but I mean this is
very comfortable as we have seen after
he takes we get this position and here
black has no problems whatsoever I have
a pretty easy game um yeah look he won
kind of normal and the engine already
points out that Knight g4 is going to be
dangerous yeah there's some truth to
that Queen f6 or Queen h4 now are quite
significant threats and the computer
already advocates rook f1 which is kind
of funky okay so I missed the chance
there not be d7
Bishop g5 and now I think this is a good
good way to play here you can argue
about Bishop b3 it looks active there
but going to e2 why if one just has its
points I mean the bishop is defending a
lot better than a funny trick that was
also possible in the game is this where
F 3 is going to be severely punished
where Bishop takes them this is the idea
and now white cannot capture due to the
queen loss but okay yeah you don't have
to play a three okay here I first played
aged six you should drop back there now
Bishop g4 the engine wants to play c6 am
I'm still a little bit surprised
oh no Bishop g4 is given preference I'm
still surprised that the engine is
already giving black some advantage not
much but it thinks that black is better
I did not really think that I was better
I was just like happy with the position
and it was fine okay I mean knight c6
interesting is this I did not think
about this move at all I should have you
know his queen is unprotected so rook
takes I mean this this is good him where
two pieces hanging so um rook takes has
to be done Queen takes whoa okay h3 and
now the engine just wants to play Queen
h5 remarkable so this is this is good
[Music]
and blacks supposed to be better a
little bit yeah I don't know I mean I
like 96 it's simple I get the bishop
pair and that's it
yeah I think you should still go to g3
and not take on f6 I would play Knight
at age 5 and simply take next this is
this is comfortable I mean very much but
I'm not winning or anything f3 is
suggested by the engine that surprises
me isn't this good
ah this strap is the night ah that's
very funny very uncommon idea ok so
actually I'm not winning the bishop pair
I can I have to go back and then and
then you can preserve it ok I mean I
have this for a decent position but it's
not something that I saw at all ok so
then then Bishop d3 is definitely
clearly better than taking and now he
went to b5 and yeah ok the engine gives
an idea for I kind of suspected that
those attacks could work I mean I'm on
that yeah but this is like it's a lazy
move I know
but yeah what you do in blitz him I will
Knight a for now would have helped him
get rid of a good pick good piece of
mine and this this shouldn't work ready
c6 also works yeah again I kind of
suspected that this could work
but I mean 95 is just a strong move we
can look at this quickly because
whatever I saw is that here I mean he's
got one check
and now the knight is hanging it has no
good squares and I'm threatening this
and this and whatever and I saw an idea
but on the other hand if I go here I'm
threatening all these attacks like this
and this and I'm threatening c6 so and
it was kind of clear that he wanted to
take on b7 and then it's definitely
killed Knight f3 is not given here as
one of the three top choices it's
irritating
it doesn't seem to win it doesn't seem
to win okay now the engine changes this
mind
I mean okay it's clear that this or or
this is also very strong and and should
win MIT okay let's have a look so takes
and the Bishop takes Bishop takes
doesn't work
Wow really no no now again the engine
changes his mind yeah okay so I mean I
did not calculate this I was just like
okay that that must win yeah I did not
did not really calculate lines Queen d5
is the only move that puts up resistance
he would have thought that rookie 636 is
enough if you get too many attacking
pieces but it was a bit of them I should
have been a little bit more thorough
there was a bit yeah okay well after 92
Queen h4 we're dealing with made and
made in some moves if he goes here Queen
age 3 as the end no and whenever he does
that yeah I'm just going to H H not
reacting him just made next move okay
interesting game thanks a lot for
watching